- Right now I'm going to show you the room
that my two children and I share,
inside my parents home.
There's a total of 10 people living here.
I am also living out of my trunk
because there's not
enough space in my room.
Come on in.
Really tight in here.
Shoes, clothes, I just try
to utilize all this space
that I can...
I have things under the bed.
Right here, I made this
little library for my boys,
they really like when I read to them.
Here's my study area.
I have shoes under the desks,
'cause I had nowhere else to put them.
And it's really hard to study right here,
when my boys are just
right behind me on the bed.
(murmurs) it's very crowded in here.
I'm just trying to do the best I can,
to make it work.
You know, I have to do what I have to do.
(audience applaud)
- I'm back with Kevin Hart and Andrea,
an aspiring nurse and single mom.
So that was a tour of the room
she shares with her two boys.
Right now, she lives in a
house with 10 other people.
Before the break, Kevin and
I Jumanji sized her Christmas
with toys and a scholarship
to finish nursing school.
While we said we're gonna
Jumanji Size her Christmas.
Right Kevin?
- [Kevin] We did say that.
- Have we done that?
- I don't think we've
completely Jumanji sized,
because Jumanji's a big movie.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- That's a really big movie.
- Exactly, I feel like we're definitely
under the bar at this point.
- [Kevin] We under the bar,
I think that we can go...
There's another level that can be reached,
you can definitely reach another level.
- All right, let's take
this Jumanji Size Christmas
one more level.
(drum roll)
Okay y'all, our friends at
xfinity also heard Andrea's story
and wanted to help.
Xfinity is providing her, and her boys
with a newly remodeled and newly furnished
two bedroom apartment,
all for them, all free.
For one whole year.
Xfinity knows that the internet
has the incredible power
to keep us all connected
and it has become vital to
living and working these days.
Because of this, xfinity
is also making sure
Andrea and her kids stay connected,
with free internet service for a year.
That is so helpful with
studying, I know that.
And we have Miguel Martinez-Valle
from our Filly Affiliate NBC10 standing by
for a grand tour of Andrea's new place.
Look at that monitor.
- Oh my God!
- [Kelly] And check our your new home.
(audience applaud)
- Hey Andrea, hey Kelly, hey Kevin.
Wait, I'm so excited to
show you your new home,
I'm gonna give you a
little tour here Andrea,
it's beautiful in here.
Let's take a look around.
So, when you walk in the front door,
the first place you're gonna
see is your kids bedroom.
The boys, they get their own bedroom,
you know, they have bunk beds right there.
You can see How to Train
Your Dragon theme in here.
It's beautiful and it comes complete,
right next to your room.
Which, own space,
I mean we were talking
about space earlier.
Look, you get your own beautiful bed
and take a look at that desk.
I know you're finishing up nursing school,
that is a prime study location,
just for you Andrea.
And then right here,
this is the family space.
So you get the kitchen,
brand new stainless steel appliances,
brand new granite counter tops.
And everything, right
next to the living room.
So, you've got that new TV
from our friends over at xfinity,
and take a look behind me here.
Because it's the holiday season,
a beautiful decorated Christmas tree
and presents for the whole family.
So this beautiful space,
it is right next to where
you're currently living.
So just a few blocks away,
the kids they can stay
in their own school.
It's so close to where you are now,
but this, it's your own.
So, I don't know, Andrea, how do you feel?
- Oh my God, I am just
blessed and grateful.
I did not expect this.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart.